to make you profitable. All right. So just as I thought you about the inverse roll you
got, so we can do the same with the auto blocks. So here, you can see that we get a market
structure shift. So now you're going to have an auto block here, consecutive bullish candles
or consecutive up closed candles. And you might have noticed that most of the time, and
I'm not saying go and watch your charts, it's going to go to the auto block, but it's
It's gonna rip through it like guys.
There's a way to take a trade from here.
So most of the time, the reason why I hate,
I'm not saying I hate but I dislike the ICT 2022 model
because once you get a market search shift
and you have your auto block here
or your free value gap, it's gonna rip through it
most of the time.
So here's how to trade it.
You have your auto block, right?
If it goes above it, right?
And first off, it has to go up, right,
wake above it or something like that, or close above it.
And then I want the body to close below the auto block,
a reclaim of auto block,
just like in virtual valley gaps.
And then the enter on the retest
and we target somewhere around here.
Very simple, right?
And if I remove the drawings right here,
you will get another type of this
where you have a break of structure, right?
And most of the SMC or ICT creators
We'll try to go along from the autoblog that should be here.
Consecutive, bearish, or consecutive, down close candles.
Now you might have noticed that price
will not react from here.
Now in most cases, in some cases, actually not most.
Yes, it can, but we have to look for a confirmation entry
like that, okay?
But what if price does this?
There's a way to enter through it, just like ABCD, right?
You wait for price to sweep the auto block, I call it the auto block liquidity, right?
This low here.
Wait for a reclaim and free on the retest and you target this.
Very simple.
This is basically, if you use these simple things, because the thing is guys, ICT has, of
course, created a lot of smart money students, okay?
He has, like, taught so many things and they work.
They work perfectly, but they didn't work straight away.
You know, each of us, every group out there,
who is like a gentleman guru,
had to go and back test for several months and years.
It wasn't like a piece of cake,
where I said to give you a strategy,
and you went onto the charts,
and then it started to work out of nowhere.
We had to test and refine things,
and when we saw these things working,
that's when we put it out on YouTube or in the courses.
So over here, this is what works.
Usually you would try to go long here,
but what happens?
We get a sweep, a reclaim,
then an entry on the re-test.
And we target this or for everybody to get around here.
Let me give you guys some examples
and then I'll end the video.